overbooking a new vaccination campaign
and even a
technical glitch all a part of today's
covid vaccination update from the
southern nevada health district
and clark county thank you for joining
us at five i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez so tonight we start with
that technical glitch what had
so many of our viewers calling into our
newsroom today christian casadas joining
us now live in the studio to break it
all down for us christian
that's right brian denise well the las
vegas convention center experienced a
system failure which forced
the the digital process to go
old-fashioned with pen and paper format
this caused some delays but we're told
that the problem will be fixed today
and the site is still operating as a
second dose site
now also we've been they've been also
talking about this for a while now the
problem
of overbooking it is still ongoing more
than 10 000 duplicate appointments
were found and it's preventing others
from getting the vaccine
we're working hard around the clock to
address
i.t issues we are working hard to
prepare in the events that we get a lot
more vaccines we have to be ready
to go and lastly i want to remind
constituents to
please please please cancel your
appointments
what we're finding is many people are
making appointments
at five six different locations and not
cancelling them
i also learned that five new cases with
the new covet variant from the uk were
reported locally last week
health officials say they are keeping a
close eye on them
but they are all related and they found
them through contract
tracing now also expect more educational
campaigns
about vaccines rolling out soon
targeting underserved communities
and the older population christian
gazette is 8 news now